taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking hey taste buddies
it's the taste buds
podcast i'm joe derosa and it's sad
volcano hi guys
good to see you good to see you good to
see all of you
all of you all of you pimp good to see
you good to be here
mm-hmm yeah good to be seen yeah there's
a lot of stuff going on
we'll be uh we'll let you know next
episode
if you're going to do the hoagie
challenge yeah and what that buy-in is
going to be
what the what you get if you win what
you get if you lose yes
yes uh we're also going to uh dip into
our record next episode
yes and uh i want to see
i don't do you want to just call it
right now that the person with the more
with the with the losing record out of
the two of us is eating that the
the sugar-free haribo gummy bears to
have explosive [ __ ]
intestinal problems yes so it's not even
like all right we'll go to episode
third like see if there's a race
oh no we said we said we'll check we'll
we'll do the update of our record on the
next episode
and then after a full year of episodes
oh a full year okay whoever the winner
is
okay we'll do that oh my gosh so we have
that coming and my friend anna
uh confirmed that it is a hundred
percent true about those gummy bears
uh she said they would eat them on dares
in the military when you like if you
lost a bet
okay she said but the one caveat is this
you have to eat the whole bag
if you don't eat the whole bag it won't
work it won't work but she said it does
because your body cannot digest some of
the chemicals in there or something
who knows what it is i think it's got
something to do with the sweetener they
use i'm just kind of running through you
okay um so okay so that's coming up
right pimp do you mind
i i don't mean to make you a secretary
uh
but do you mind uh writing down the
contest thing for the next episode and
the um
hoagie challenge i just don't want to
make sure i don't forget we're going to
forget
none of us can remember a thing around
here you know what i mean yup
faster pimp let's go let's go
honey i started talking over sexual
sexually
honey babe can you come in here babe i
need you to write this down honey
ooh you look cute today
[Laughter]
so like mad men yeah yeah exactly yeah
anyway so that stuff is coming up what
we're gonna do now in the episode here
before we get into our big this
and i have a feeling this one's gonna
get a little hot today but we have here
uh do you wanna do this first we'll do
uh we gotta we got the no push pack from
saratoga in hand
yeah uh labels are really fun uh we
paired up with the no pressure network
to create this special no pressure pack
no we just peed oh wait you're reading
that sorry yeah
i'm sorry you're reading their thing and
i thought you were saying to the fans
we teamed up with the no pressure
network and i was like no we are
hitting the head with a rock or anything
sorry okay i'm sorry it includes two
specialty nut butter blends made
just for our favorite guys uh thanks sal
and joe for the shout outs on taste bud
podcast a portion of the sales
we donate to charity prevent child abuse
dot org it's really really good so i've
tried i've already gone through
one of each of these in the last week or
so i have not tried it yet i just got
mine in the mail
um and i have not had the opportunity
yet to eat it and then i was here today
and sal said why don't we try it
why don't you try it on air for the
first time so i'm trying both of these
and i'd like to be frank with everyone i
love peanut butter and i already love
this company and these i i burned
through
a set already in like a week they're
absolutely delicious
you're a little nervous because you're
not as big a fan of these flavor
profiles in a general sense
butterscotch was never like a thing that
you loved
so you were a little nervous uh i'm not
a huge butterscotch guy
i'm not crazy about you and i don't like
chris right so
we're not off to a good start
uh no butterscotch in general i like it
sometimes i don't always like it
this is i'm holding the hey babe one
which is white chocolate almond butter
with blueberries yeah
you know usually you know i'm not an
artisan type guy
yeah you know yeah but wait do you have
saratoga this isn't really all i mean i
don't know these these
these flavors all go together amazing
and what's so good about the no press
pack and we don't get any money from
this just so you know but what's so good
about it is they're so different
this is like they're completely two
different tastes one's an almond butter
with blueberries one is
a peanut butter with butterscotch a lot
sweeter not too sweet
but just sweeter i think they are
absolutely fantastic right out of the
juice we're going in
first on the hay bay what i did was i
brought a knife in case you wanted to
take it out with the knife
and then put it from the knife to the
spoon in case you want to go back in
you see what i'm saying because i don't
want you to put your mouth on that and
then go back in that would be
that would be absurd even for someone
not of my standards with germs
i got you understand you understand
would you
would you do that with anybody or just
me anyone okay
i want to make sure you're going to
double dip your spoon out of your mouth
into my no it's a good
house peanut butter that's a good point
that's a good point
remember the seinfeld where george eats
his peanut butter george
dips in his fingers and jerry's peanut
butter because they did that to me
i wouldn't say one thing people have
aroma there was a throwaway line i did
on a
on a set at this is not happening uh
where i say i'm allergic to peanut
butter
and i'm not people always like how are
you allergic to meanwhile are you you
talk about
i'm not it just was a one throw away
line joke in the whole goddamn thing
there was two things in that story that
were just throwaway jokes that i riffed
on stage that got less and i kind of
kept in that regret
but one of them was that i'm allergic to
peanut butter which is funny in the
moment but i'm not so mystery solved
okay yeah all right it smells great it's
got a nice smell i'm excited nice smell
yeah oh yeah ready yeah
this is delightful it is right yeah
right that's really nice i'm telling you
um sometimes the blueberries uh
you gotta mix it a little bit because
they get settled on the bottom
well i actually tried
i actually was gonna say
i like it because it starts with a with
a slightly salted almond butter flavor
which then transitions into a white
chocolate
and then it finishes with a hint of
blueberry it's very nice
isn't it nice yeah so i gotta put okay
okay you know what we're gonna do
what are we gonna do i'm just gonna use
both spoons okay
and i'm not gonna double dip and you're
not gonna eat anything
okay because not to be rude
not to be rude but you've eaten this
already and there's no way i'm getting
that knife back to the spoon without
contaminating the knife
no just rub the knife on there i already
touched the spoon with it i already
have messed up but do whatever you like
i've messed up this system
i'm gonna lick this knife off to not
spill it okay now you could have just
put that knife right back in there but
you had more you really do like it
no that's not why you oh cause his knife
was gonna have to go into there
okay but it already had this on it three
utensils and you couldn't cover this
no i can you just can't have it i
noticed you take the
the foil topping off a hundred percent
sometimes i i peel it back but then i
leave it
in its shape so that when i close it
there's an extra how did you peel that
back i had to cut it with a knife
yeah but you kind of like
do this oh that one this one didn't have
that paper part on it
and i leave it there this didn't have
the paper part which
yeah this just had foil across it didn't
have the paper
maybe you got a maybe you got one of the
uh now can i take this off to set the
utensils down on
is that one on this they were in my
mouth
do it do it it's a small container yeah
but now you're gonna lose all that
it's
hey come on dude it's wasteful it's not
wasteful it's i mean you're wasting a
whole thing there
the whole thing it literally is like
well move the spoon so they see because
he's getting a shot of it now
you got a whole coating that's the whole
that's the waste that much
peanut butter oh i i grew up i don't
know the knife didn't even stick to it
it's so little
all right yeah i think it's wasteful all
right here we go
now peanut butter this is taste buds
right yeah butterscotch
oh man i had this on bread the other day
okay lights out
man it's so creamy i know it is
wow just give it a try he doesn't like
butterscotch but no i
don't i don't dislike butterscotch i
like it sometimes sometimes i don't like
it
i can tell you right away people must
you guys can freak out now we're
actually trying foods on here
all the people that want to hear our lip
smacking
that has a this just has such a
christmasy smell to it oh my favorite
holiday
mine too just really does smell like
holiday issues think
it's like a winter wonderland just think
of the season
come on tell me about that finish
tell me about that finish it comes right
back around to the peanut right
really good man i'm telling you yeah
yeah it's so
good you wouldn't you wouldn't you
wouldn't bs me right i mean
it'd be crazy no it'd be crazy
like this is horse no but i could tell
that you're being serious though
it is good right it's delicious i know
it is
the the the taste buds one tastes like
um
i'm not just saying this i like the
taste what's more better
they're both good but i love them both
they they're for two different needs
yeah i agree
but i got i went through the taste buds
one quicker but they're
they're literally just as good they're
just different one is sweeter
and one is more like one i do way more
with a sandwich and one is more like a
snack
that taste buds one you put that on ice
cream it's game oh my god oh my god
i didn't even think of that that is game
over on ice cream
i think that's what it's reminding me of
is when you have a peanut butter and an
ice cream the way the peanut butter
starts to taste
yeah because the cream we should do it
we should get vanilla ice cream
galactose superior i gotta get lactose
free for me but yeah
and then just scoop it and do a little
swirl
low in carbs and sugar too mix that all
up dude yeah oh [ __ ] this is great work
great work shark target thank you thank
you we're honored to be working with you
guys on a good cause
i ordered five cases already now and i
gave them out to family and friends i'm
gonna order more now
man that's good that's good stuff i'm
glad you like it oh one other thing
yeah god that came in the mail
i said salva's present this week
uh and it didn't even occur to me to
talk about it on the show
until it was here and i was on my way
over there and i was like that's
ridiculous
we should talk about that on the show
but we we were out we were out
we were out last week or whatever and
you you said i think i
i i i think i saw something that i think
you'd really like
and then yeah this thing is great this
is
a like a wooden bamboo
cutting board slash
charcuterie tray cheese serving tray
that has a built-in
drawer with utensils
i mean if you're someone who likes to
uh to have company like i do
i like to have people over i do like a
dinner party thing with drinks and
and we do like you know all sorts of
like treats and food out on the table
i really like to host and he knows that
i'm thinking of cheese here grapes here
a salam here yeah maybe another cheese
there
maybe grapes in the middle for an extra
salam
yeah you're right gracious crack is
going
i like to place them in between
everything oh i like that spread it
around
and then if you want to have an uncut
cheese you got all your utensils in here
this did just give me a splinter no i
apologize
did it really it's me it's solid it's
heavy it's smooth
you could kill a man with this yeah you
could kill someone with that
if you had to look how nice it's
embossed i like that word embossed
i like a good embossment yeah well there
it is yeah we're at a bar and i said i
was gonna buy that for you you pulled it
up on the phone
you're like would you like this or not
i'm like i would like it let's do this
look at this look at all the fun
there's even the bamboo handles on the
skewers
yeah very nice stuff what's that thing
oh that's look at these
oh what is that they're little signs
that you write on if they're chalkboards
yes they're mini chalkboards that you
stick in the cheese
that is so cool that is precious i know
it is precious
look at that they're little slates i
know that is precious
it really is cool
uh mine is always sharp vermont cheddar
i love extra sharp white vermont cheddar
is my favorite of all time
i mean fresh mozzarella anything you're
not beating freshman so now
just walk it down i'll do sharper
montreal versus
cheddar i wouldn't cross the street for
it but listen
that that would be a really good battle
because both cheeses really have a stake
in what they do what are these little
cigarettes
yeah these if you just want to start
smoking again
i'll tell you what these are if they're
just looking for a moment these are
two
slate slate friendly inks
to write the signage with the reason you
didn't recognize them is they went so
far as to
wrap the markers in a bamboo like
sticker okay so that it it matches the
wooden texture
of the entire aesthetic little wine
opener
i mean they're going the extra mile is
what you need to know here
you thought these were utensils in them
themselves because they did such a good
job
making them look like little bamboo
sticks that's a really
i gotta be i might buy one of these now
i might have my
thing about you have company you have a
lady friend over a nice a gal
and you come in and there is labeled
slate
cheese on on a beautiful board with a
pullout
you i'm gonna say something right now
you that's that's impressive that's nice
work
it's impressive that's nice work it's
heavy enjoy it and be well
thank you so much thank you i so much
appreciate it you're welcome i'm so
excited to use it for the first time
pimp you start coming to the bars with
us who knows maybe you get a couple
gifts in the mail
you know that's what happens at uh
you know at the you know five or six
drinks
[Laughter]
gifts stuff being thrown around yeah we
were at uh
that
we went to a show at arrogant swine in
bushwick which is a fun
great restaurant by the way great
barbecue restaurant if you like uh
barbecue
i've met the owner several times she's
very nice nice staff
very nice staff great show area in the
back
but uh there was a uh a staffer there in
particular who was quite excited that
you were in
that you were present and uh
he was he was very uh uh attentive
with the drinks yeah
so yeah there's tequila yeah yeah it was
fun
yeah and then we left and we went to
then we had a [ __ ] show of service at
the next bar
that was terrible oh there was a drunk
there was a there was a bla we caught
you ever catch people
that you know they're in the black in a
blackout we were going into
just for a quick late night bite with a
couple of friends and there was a girl
that was
in a blackout phase i literally told the
guy who was seating us i was like
you should really not serve her like
anymore if you could help it
because you could tell like the girl
couldn't even stand up straight she was
so obnoxious she's like
yo pull down your mask
i was like i don't understand like why
would i do that she's like just pull it
down
she she like wailed into me and i was
like oh you're okay and i realized she
was drunk and i'm like everything okay
and she's like
pull down your mask yeah i'm not gonna
do that
and she was like like she was like like
you ever see the cartoons where they
like hiccup and it's like a bubble comes
out like
their eyes are like bloodshot she looks
like a cartoon cat
and it was one of those yeah that was a
that was
that was poof she was a lot yeah she was
a lot to handle
but she was a lot to handle but the food
was good the food was good
it was the food was good unhealthy but
good
yeah it was it was very good it was very
good we don't know the name of the place
but
yeah i can't remember either whatever it
doesn't matter arrogant swine check it
out that's the other place
uh what does blackout junk actually mean
joe
means that you don't remember anything
temporary condition that affects your
memory
characterized by a sense of lost time
blackouts occur when your body's alcohol
levels are high
alcohol impairs your ability to form new
memories
while intoxicated it doesn't erase
memories formed before intoxication
that is unbelievable we've all been
there
interesting yeah it's been a while for
me
but blackout well no that's not true
i got kind of blackout drunk recently
but prior to that about three years and
then prior to that was probably
three years and then you could go back
to our college days where it was like
you know
you probably would drink it too much um
oh good i
i brown out more than i black out what
is it brownout
it's when it's just kind of spotty right
before a blackout it's just like it
means it's
it's like spotty yeah like you're like
wait where did we oh yeah that's right
yeah you know yeah that kind of thing
yeah sure that's that's that's more like
it yeah but i
i won't black out i can't blackout is
the worst feeling
in the it's the worst feeling it's not a
good feeling and i i it takes
days to recover from blackout yeah oh
you're just not yourself you got the
shakes you're just on not on steady
ground
yeah you're just questioning your
choices there's a hint of shame involved
you know you forget who you spoke to
what you said what you looked like
that on that that big question mark is
frightening that's not a good feeling
who would i talk to who'd i text who'd i
yeah
what did i tweet what did i do this what
i you know what i mean
yeah it's not a good feeling dude it's
not a good feeling and
well the worst feeling is is when you
black out
you're aware that you're being a little
like rowdy
you know you're going up the the right
and you're like and you're and then you
black out and you're like oh
jesus where did that end up
yeah like that's a frightening feeling
honestly if you've if you've gotten away
after a blackout without anything too
bad happening
to you or others you know you've made
out okay
because i'm not surprised because
nobody's really accountable during that
you could god forbid you don't know what
you're doing you know i mean that's
where a lot of the
i mean you know god you know don't drive
or anything like that but
never that's one thing like that's the
severe but i just mean like
what you say to people what a fool you
make of yourself who you talk to
maybe who knows what yeah it's just
crazy
you know that kind of thing it's just
crazy man
just uh yeah i see this uh there was
please love you i insist one time i saw
it
i i did you know that kardashian show i
guess it's called keeping up with
traditions
um i i haven't seen it in my life like a
full episode or anything
but i've seen clips and
i've seen one clip like four times by
chance and i don't know if it's because
it's a famous clip
and this is the only like kind of
reference point i have for the show
and it was very troubling to me and i
always wondered if
the boyfriend on it of one of them um
the one he's uh uh he
maybe his name's scott okay yes yes yes
so scott uh i don't know who which
sister
he was the boyfriend of but uh he on an
episode
at a restaurant he i i'm assuming he was
black
i really hope that's the case but he
took up money
and shoved it in the waiter's mouth for
a tip oh jesus
and i just was like what is going on
here oh my god and i gotta be honest
like i'm wondering if that was a
blackout scenario
or if he just yeah or if he just like
was like
i i it gave me such a bad taste for the
show
that's what gave you the bad taste all
right well
even for him i'm sure he yeah there it
is i'm sure he's
hates that this is out there and hates
that he did it but i was like shocked
i also think you have to be a certain
level of [ __ ] to begin with
to do something like this when you're
blackout drunk
you know also you're on camera
was that real yeah i think it's real
yeah i mean i i i don't think that that
just i've never been a big
year since i've done that i've never
been a big believer in booze turned you
into
yeah oh sorry no it's okay uh
i didn't i didn't stamp at home hard
enough i guess but you know what i mean
yeah i i i don't think it necessarily i
think it uninhibits you and i think it
amplifies but i i
you know it's like if you do awful
things when you're
drunk you know look and and you don't do
them when you're not drunk then great
then don't drink
right but also too it's i i'm a i'm a
blee i tend to believe that no man
there's something lurking around in you
that's like
fueling that he's got a heal he's not
coming from out of nowhere
yeah if i if i don't know what would you
know maybe he had no control i don't
know i can't say that i
could speak for anything i do it on
black i drunk but if i ever especially i
was on a show
on a show or whatever and i came back
and that was on camera
i may retreat into the shadows forever
that's
that embarrassment but i mean you gotta
you gotta be so offensive you gotta put
it in perspective of who the guy is and
this is kind of what i know the guy
might be a good guy maybe you've made a
mistake i don't know
please i don't know yeah hey come on
dude it's like
this is like people that are willing to
put show their ass on camera like this
metaphorically um it's like they're
they're
they're cut from a different cloth than
you you know what i mean like it's like
you would never
you would never invite cameras into your
home for dinner
right you know you'll sit and eat with
the jokers on
zoom right you know as a goof or
whatever but it's like you would never
invite cameras into your christmas tree
traditional reality stuff yeah like
forget it
not for me
i'm sure i have i mean i don't you know
what i mean yeah
yeah i mean i don't know well no i know
recently i got
i got drunk and threw up like while i
was out and that
or i was felt like i was gonna throw up
and that was like literally like i can't
do that [ __ ] no more
it was like you know what it was i
hadn't i i just i didn't eat that day i
was having a really bad day
i hadn't really like gone out that was
the first time i went out
in months and months and months and i
just had too much and it caught up to me
i didn't mean it
and it was so freaking i was i don't
know no one cared but i mean like you
know
i'm you know you can't be doing that
[ __ ] at this age
the uh yeah the the worst thing i could
say is like
look i definitely when i was younger you
know you're 22
you get drunk yeah you heckle a band or
something
like a cover band or something because
you think it's funny you're trying to
you know that that's more like a product
of age or whatever
but uh i would say no usually like i
could do something like that actually i
was very embarrassed
what's that there was a okay i'm going
to tell you a story there was an
it was a discotek a nightclub right
in queens i think it was called metro
metropolis i think or metronome or
something like that metro
and they had this deal where before 11
it was open bar
and that's because they want to get
everybody in early you know whatever so
we would go
travel all the way out there and we'd go
and get it might have been beer only
but we go and we we get lit you know
before it starts before the bar started
charging we get lit up so
i was nice and toasted and
there was a guy there his name was he
was he was singing
he was saying his name was
his name was franklin fuentes okay
uh this is back speaking of freestyles
back like not that era but like
maybe this was like the late 90s and
this guy had a song called
um i think it was called x
okay it's like excuse me who's the dj
and he's like x x x
excuse me yeah yeah there it is all
right so this is club song
[Laughter]
and this is a 10 minute version of it
and i'm we're not allowed to play it of
course right
so he's singing he's a little
entertainment that night they have
you know and then before it goes back to
the michael and he was singing and i
don't know
i didn't again again i didn't mean for
this but i guess i was pretty drunk and
i i had a for some reason i had a dixie
cup
full of skittles i don't know i don't
know why i had skittles right
i it's it's unclear but i had one of
those clear dixie cups of skills and i
took a skittle and i threw it at the
stage
okay i just lofted a skittle you know i
was back though
no joke 100 feet okay at least okay i
launched it i don't know why i do a
skittle right i guess it was open bar
right and this skittle
as he was singing and if he if franklin
fuentes if you're watching him we know
you are
uh it hit him in the front tooth while
he was singing
didn't break his tooth or anything but
it just
we saw it go and he hit his tooth and
shot out the other way and he was like
and they just kept singing but i i feel
like it's not that bad well i feel
freaking terrible about it
right i mean i get you but that was 25
years ago i think about to this day like
what a dick
uh i was blackout now is it shoving
money down someone's throat no
but hey maybe maybe i should just
i can't throw stones really i can't
throw skittles i ca
yeah no i can't think of a i can't
i never did that i don't know what my
end game was i just launched
when you're young and you drink you get
done like i said you had you you you
know i remember heckle and a guy a cover
band saying they sucked until the guy
came off stage and like kind of dressed
me down
but like did it in a did it in a very
charming way that made him look great
and made me look like an [ __ ] but i
was like i was 21. you know and
you're at some [ __ ] drink special
where it's like 75 cent drinks on a
thursday or whatever
you know but after that like at this age
you know blackout you know you're still
mortified but uh
you know i don't know it's like you know
i don't know i got maybe you throw up in
public or something i gotta create
another
wild one i was out at key west with
fantasy fest
uh it's basically mardi gras but it's
even it's like mardi gras for like
hippies
it's a lot of it's a lot of like older
people they all walk around nude but
they do that spray paint art
and there's like just this is a real
weird eclectic
retirees and stuff down there and
free-flowing people
it's like it's like be a beatnik town
it's very laid-back you know the keys
floor you know key west and like you'll
you'll even see people like walking like
like a woman walking their uh their
partner on a leash like it's just a
freaky like it's like mermaid
festivities
mardi gras meets uh what's that one in
rio in
uh brazil and uh what's the the big the
big thing they have
in rio carnival it's it's it's like a
truncated version of that right so so
we're in this bar i think it was called
the hogs bretzel it's a famous bar down
there
and they're having um i guess a
bikini contest or a whatever contest i
don't know if it was a dancing contest
but
but everyone is in costume this is the
whole thing everyone's in costume down
there right
so everyone is drinking i mean the way
this place
did people drink down there is crazy
right so i'm actually with q
right and with brian johnson yeah yeah i
went down there for brian johnson's
birthday i think it was it was in
december i'll never forget it because it
was 95 degrees
but they all had christmas decorations
up so it was like a wild thing
and where i this and we're at this bar
and we're drinking and we're drinking
and they're like all right we're going
to have this contest now by round
applause how you vote
and whoever wants to get in the contest
you go and it was a big u-shaped bar so
they'd invite women maybe men too i
don't remember but i just remember they
invite women to get up and like their
costume
would they would walk to you over the
bar and then by round of applause you'd
vote and i think the like the winner was
getting cash
like big cash you know so you know
people getting up with
is that and then a girl gets up a woman
gets up she is
like a flawless like she's like perfect
like her body
everything and she is she's wearing a
bikini
made only homemade out of post-it notes
okay wow it's j i mean literally
post-it notes so like she's also
counting on them sticking to her
but they're like going covering the
front yeah the back and then like her
rest and everything right and she calls
herself the secretary
and the place goes wild right everyone's
like sexy
it was like it was i've never seen a
post-it no bikini before
so not even the fact that she was she
was you know very
very beautiful but it was like the fact
that she was very innovative
right so that combination really won
over this hogg's breast
saloon drunk sure and um
did anyone ever do it you see it posted
no bikini we googled it doesn't come up
this is what i'm saying
it doesn't even come up on google that's
how original the secretary was
wow you guys know the podcast in the
podcast world and you're no stranger to
blue chew
blue chew unique online service that
delivers you the same active ingredients
as viagra
cialis but but but
in a chewable form which i like yeah all
right
and also at a fraction of the cost which
i like yeah
there you go if you're sick of
swallowing pills are you one of those
people that has a hard time doing it you
chew this one
blue shoes have blue blue blue blue blue
blue juice tablets
i sound like max headroom ready
bluetooth tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections to combat all
forms of e.d
eric town dysfunction blue chew is an
online prescription service so there's
no doctor visits there's no awkward
conversations
there's no waiting in line at the
pharmacy it ships right to your door in
discreet packaging i think that's really
the best aspect of what they're doing i
mean obviously affordable is great
obviously chewable is great
and blue is a fun color but i like that
it's so online and discreet this could
be an embarrassing
you know it could be it doesn't have to
talk about exactly
so i think that's really cool so listen
we got a special deal for the listeners
if this is something you're interested
in you can try blue chew for
free when you use our promo code which
is taste buds
at checkout all you're going to pay is
five bucks on shipping how are you not
interested in that
i don't know i'm just saying i don't
have to go get a prescription it was
like a thing
now it's free and you get it delivered
to your door by clicking a button how
are you not interested for five bucks
it's bluechew.com promo code tastebuds
to receive
your first month free
thanksgiving right thank you bluechu
yeah thank you from us
thank you for our listeners thank you
for all the erections around the world
listen
you hear that that's the sound of
bluetooth erections
joey this podcast is sponsored by better
help and if you don't know
better help is blowing up across the
country it is
uh better help is great if there's
something interfering with your
happiness
or maybe something preventing you from
achieving your personal goals
uh or even professional goals or any
sorts of goals i
have talked about better help in the
past on this show and
i will say it again that something or
somebody for
me is chris destefano
he absolutely is an interference and a
hindrance on my life and my happiness
and better help will help me assess the
needs i need
and match me with somebody a licensed
professional to be more specific
a therapist that's going to help me work
through that you can start communicating
in under 48 hours this is not a crisis
line it's not a self-help
cell it's not self this is not a crisis
line it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online and look
we make jokes here we have fun but in
all seriousness
this is a really wonderful wonderful
wonderful
service being provided to people and to
make something like this
this accessible is really a beautiful
thing i don't know if you've ever gone
through the ringer of trying to get
traditional health care uh for your
mental state
even finding a therapist therapist
counseling whatever i'm a lifelong
therapy patient
it can be very daunting and when you're
in the state that you're in
sometimes when you need to pursue
therapy the last thing you feel like
doing is running through some obstacle
course
yeah and phone numbers and all these
things and that's the year or two that
we've had too a lot of people are
looking for
just just some outlet you go to visit
you visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds uh it's betterhelp help
and join over one million people who've
taken charge of their mental health
with the help of experienced
professionals it's it's actually
becoming so popular
that they mentioned that they're
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 of the states
yes so taste buds listeners you're gonna
get 10 off your first month
just go to betterhelp.com
taste buds they're there to help so the
place is going nuts she has won the
hearts and minds of the hog's breath
saloon
okay we're we're standing there and then
there's all these guys girls
everyone's drunk there's a guy next to
me and a guy next to him
and we're all like yeah the guy's like
you know like yeah we might have
exchanged a couple of words we're both
drinking
you know definitely like we had broached
each other
right that way that was like we made we
might have said a couple of things to
each other during the thing and
right right and then okay so so we
establish a rapport
in a way right okay and then we're all
drunk and everyone's like sex
or terry and then the next girl gets up
after sexetary
fine fine looking perfect no a little
bit of a different body type
nothing bad not bad at all nothing bad
but just not she wasn't in a bikini of
post-its
right and everyone turned on the next
girl because
they were like no and there and so we
yeah everybody
follow sex attack right how do you
follow sexetary
so i'm like bo no we want sex
i'm like we want sexy terry back like it
was really pro-secretary not not
pro her right and we're just like get
out of the way we need we need
secretary and i'm just screaming and i
go come on
we want secretary and then i turn the
guy's looking at me like this and i go
out he goes that's my wife and i was
like oh my god
and he's like you got because when you
said dress you down right yeah he goes
you got something to say that's my
freaking wife
and i was like oh look man i'm just
cheering the favorite costume whatever
he's like no
and he shoves me like we were just
talking but everyone's so drunk
you know and the guy i don't know if
he's black or whatever and he shoves me
and i'm like
look i'm like we're not going to fight
here it was blacked
i don't know okay but he shoved me
almost immediately he's like that's my
wife
and then he kept like coming up to me
like going like that when he was like
talking
like pointing at me like no you said
what you said that's my wife you don't
disrespect my wife but i didn't say
anything i literally was just like no we
want secretary back
yeah isn't that what you were that's
what she was hoping you would do right
well sex is that the point secretary was
she did her walk
right and now the next girl had to do
her work but i'm saying the point is is
the
excitement from the crowd the vote that
you want to win
yeah you're voting for his wife yes no
not his wife
i wanted secretary back oh i thought you
were saying secretary was his wife
no oh see now you got a problem
the probably me like thing that he took
offense to the most i swear is this is
this innocent i went
boom
because it's a cheering competition i go
we want secretary and then he was like
what are you doing he shoved me i go
what he goes that's my wife
and i was like oh yeah and then he's
doing it to me and i go and i'm like
listen
and i didn't know what to say to him but
i was so drunk and i was like i just
looked at him
and i was like i did what i did i booed
him but he's got to listen to reason
so like i just looked at him i was like
look man i was like i have no problem
with you or your wife she's probably a
lovely person i go but
i just want the sexes
i got like real sincere i was like i
looked them like and i we were looking
right at each other's eyes and i was
just like
you know i just it's more about
secretary and less about your wife
i just really want sexy terry to come
back and he was like
all right all right all right fine and
then the competition
ends secretary wins his wife
gets off stage and then comes to join
him and i'm not even thinking that she's
gonna join us
and she gets there and and he goes honey
he goes i want you to meet these guys
here these are my friends and she goes
hey oh hey how you doing i go good good
and he goes you know they were booing
you for a minute and she's like well and
he goes
but they just would cheer in really for
secretary and she goes all right all
right all right
and then he goes i swear to you she had
on a tube top right
i have a picture of this he goes show me
your tits
[Laughter]
she did to be unfair she flashed him
when she was on the stage
it's like mardi gras there you know what
i mean but but it was so funny because
he was he was about to fight me
and he was like shoving me three minutes
like five minutes earlier
and then and then i wasn't expecting and
then he goes yeah you know these are
good guys we're hanging out he goes
he likes size ws
what an [ __ ] because it was all that
she was got nothing to do with his wife
she was like
she was like cool and she just wanted it
it's his ego and she's like get in here
and then we all took a picture together
it's his ego he's offended yeah about
sexitary he's you know what i mean
it's all his yeah what a jerk off that's
a good story yeah
yeah yeah and big breasts
bigger than secretaries you know so if
you're watching
you know everything it's just you know
what episode this is 2003.
that's a crazy yeah that's crazy you
know what's our place
maybe not you often see breasts are we
doing taste buds
yeah i thought we were
uh place you often see breasts sometimes
in a movie
nice and today's debate we got to get to
it man
we got to get to it that's a good story
jesus
christ all right all right folks we're
debating best
movie theater candy today
this was born out of the snickers kitkat
debate yeah
uh this came up during the kitkat debate
uh
i don't remember how much of what we are
about to discuss was mentioned but as
you know from the title of the video
we're debating razornets versus
snow caps sal you want to tell the
people what team you're on
[ __ ] i spelt snow caps wrong in the
tweet
that's okay i'm going guys
listen to me take your guesses now but
i'm telling you right now for me it is
no competition i'm going with what i
think is the best movie theater
snack i can't believe i spelled it wrong
it's snow caps
chocolate non-parels what a wasteful
candy these things
are you wouldn't need nothing people
people
ride or die for snow caps nobody has
ever ridden or didn't for snow cats
i did not have i did not have the taste
i didn't have the palette for snow caps
as a child because it's a bit of a
darker chocolate it's a palette
yeah and it was my talents go to all the
time and i was like what is this crazy
old guy
this crazy you know the 35 year old guy
getting with snow caps i don't get it he
would want to you know why i think he
got him here's the first one
i didn't like him so maybe i mean i
wouldn't eat all his candy but he loved
them and then it wasn't until later in
life that i realized i had it you're
saying no no cap awakening here's how
you know they suck
here's how you know they suck they were
invented in the 1920s
and have not been updated since any
candy that all determine updated sucks
my friend i would argue the exact
opposite my friends
i would argue any candy that came out in
the 20s and didn't have to make
any changes whatsoever is perfection
and they know what they're doing and
they don't need any candy they don't
need bells and whistles they don't need
new flavors
even the likes of snickers cake candy
every single candy bar you could mention
has had variants any candy invented in
the 1920s and didn't change
has only ever been eaten by nuns and
dock workers
and that is the truth that is the truth
that is the absolute truth came around
on snow caps it was like a mind
explosion
i was like and there's so many they last
a long they last a long time okay
you could ration them out yeah here we
go
come on say it you know you want to say
it say it i actually like the little bit
of weight that they have
because what i love doing is i love
tossing around inside my hand like a
pair of dogs
unlike a combo look at these disgusting
so good and you know what else
you got to melt the chocolate melts but
then you're left with the little white
candy balls
and they give you a great crunch and
they never melt with the chocolate
so if you want to not bite them and let
the chocolate melt then all of a sudden
you paint you're playing like a little
ping pong
this is what happens it's like the
lottery number balls in your mouth
they're popping around they're hopping
around over there
up into the roof up into the sides and
then you hear them you get almost like a
satisfaction
of cracking them too like you do a
bubble wrap oh my god and then they see
what happened
nestle this is what happened over at
nestle hey boss
what should we do with all these
chocolate chips we got left over um
i don't know smoosh them down and call
them caps yeah but they're still just
chocolate chips
we got to do something is there any of
that termite
poison still around roll them in some of
that white [ __ ]
and call them snow caps and now you got
a candy and that's how you make an extra
dollar in this business son
you haven't that man's name was william
randolph hearst
who went on to disgrace this country in
numerous ways you you have a set on you
because you're arguing for raisinets
raisins
which is by baby by most accounts baby
by most accounts people are either
pro or hate raising baby now throw them
and you want to go here with me you are
going to go here i got to be in the
dude i got to be in the mood for race
first of all raising
even raisin bran sometimes i mean and
i'm like all right get out of here
get out of here you're not i don't want
just tons you're
nuts you're not okay grapes listen
here's here's here let me let me do my
little spiel now
okay raisins one of the most delightful
little
dried fruit treats you could ever have
it is a classic
it is a wonderful little treat raisin
bran of delicious cereal let's not get
into the attributes of raisins but
they've got
raisin oatmeal cookies raisins are a
wonderful wonderful treat
you take those you dip those in milk
chocolate
and you dump those into a yellow box
that looks like
sunshine itself and you are on your way
to the movies my friend
there is they are delightful these this
is dude
you could mix the this is one of the
ones you could mix in with the popcorn
do you ever mix raisin that's in with
popcorn it's the same
so everyone who thinks that raisinx with
popcorn is like your
you know your own proprietary blend
everybody does that
but it's not just done with raisin eggs
so everybody calm down with your
argument of
put them in the popcorn because snow
caps go right into the popcorn as well
what year were razornets made pimp
snow caps are the worst
snow caps are the worst movie candy
screen crush
no caps are the worst movie candy and i
don't understand why someone would eat
them
oh you want to read his article for your
own every part
look at his red vines right under it as
they should be
this person's insane mind cap army will
rock go to the front of this hold on
sal are you itching for the outdoors oh
my god
i just i just unearthed my barbecue for
the season
i love it i opened it up i scrubbed it
down
oh i didn't i'm not gonna lie to you
i'm itching for the outdoors when i'm
outdoors i'm itchy
i want to get out there it's an itch
you're itching for it baby not everyone
has convenient access to high quality
meats true or false
true well and what do you do during
grilling season if you don't where do
you go
to the restaurant no oh
butcher box yes oh i'm confused no
you said where do you go i thought if
you don't have it at home you had a
ghost if you don't have access to high
quality meats where do you go to get
high
you stay right home yeah because butcher
box delivers high quality meats right to
your doorstep
i didn't literally praise that i thought
like i have no options now i got to go
spend
five times more money at a restaurant
because i need my meat
don't do that don't do that today's
sponsor butcher box believes everyone
deserves high quality
humanely sourced meat butcher box
couldn't be easier
i've used it we've both used it you sign
up you select your box they ship it
right to your door
every month and new members will get
free bacon for
life when they sign up what
what how's that even possible we were
talking about what a year's supply was
what is a lifetime supply
i mean wait i don't care what you say
you better drop what you're doing right
now
and go get free bacon in my life a
butcher box came
uh to my house a couple of weeks ago i'm
almost out of it
did the pork chop i've done the bacon
already i did a nice skirt steak
i mean it's it's just great i did a
roast i did strip steaks
yeah i did chicken uh it's a no-brainer
it's the best meat shipped right to your
door
less trips to the grocery store um it's
the way meat should be
each box has about nine to 11 pounds of
meat right you're gonna get maybe 24
meals out of that
it's packed fresh it's shipped frozen
vacuum sealed
so it stays that way and i could have
tested that i actually
took one of the steaks out of my freezer
and left it in my fridge
and then i went home to visit my visit
my parents for almost a week
and i came back and i was like oh i
wasted that stink it's going to be bad
it was as fresh as the day it was born
that's the vacuum sealed baby yeah so go
to butcherbox.com
taste buds that's butcherbox.com
slash taste buds to receive bacon for
life
backed by pop of demand receive bacon
for life right now
new members can get bacon for life when
they sign up that's a package of free
bacon
in every box for life well for the life
of your subscription
yeah yeah but yeah if it if you want to
like they're gonna keep giving it to you
it's pretty good yeah butcherbox.com
taste buds go to the top of this pimp
because this is what you want to see
these are the words i'll tell you this
about i spelled snow caps
wrong so i'll tell you this what up pimp
go up to that stay on the box for a
second
i'll tell you this pimp and sound listen
to me because these are the words you're
looking for when you want a delicious
movie theater sweet treat right
semi-sweet not real
how do you pronounce that is it
for reals these are the words you look
for in the front of the candy box when
you want to have a good time at the
movies
but type in non i never really
understood it's almost like non-fiction
uh non-pro why are they called
non-parels
oh there it is there's a pronunciation
right there turn it up man
non-perel an unrivaled or matchless per
that's not a flat round candy made of
chocolate covered with sugar sprinkles
but why is it called that
well hold on the noun the so non-perel
is an actual word meaning an unrivaled
or
matchless person or thing so never has a
word
and on right it's in the name it's so i
mean give me a break
all right pimp non-pero let me read this
oh sorry
nonpareils are dark chocolate discs that
are sprinkled with small white candy
balls
the name actually actually refers to the
small candy balls
and is from the french word without an
equal okay we think that putting them on
dark chocolate is an excellent delivery
system
snow capsules you got to get rid of the
version you got to get rid of them you
you know so you don't even like
understand that article you don't have
big non-perel's either
no you're kidding me big chocolate dish
what are you artificial intelligence i
want to read so to say you right now i
want to read some of this article snow
caps if you have fortunate enough to
avoid them in your life
are described in their box as semi-sweet
chocolate not morales not brows are
little white sugar balls on top
especially in the dark of a movie
theater they give these chocolate mounds
the appearance of tiny
snow-covered mountain sense snow cap i
will concede the name is mildly clever
pop a bunch in your mouth at once and it
feels like you're chewing a handful of
mud that's been coated with sand
no way i wholeheartedly disagree
he's making a case that the per that the
white candy balls
are not good i love them for the texture
one of the oldest candy brands in
america
nothing old in america is good sal it's
never
good you kid don't you dare spin that
[ __ ] look at this look at one of the
oldest
candy brands in america look at the time
look at what they're up next to with the
other old candy brands mary jane's
bitter honey abba i mean just the
axis of evil you brought it up last show
this is
this is the mount rushmore of hate of
candy
those are the those are the candy bars
that have stood the test of a hundred
years
and you take those four snow caps mary
jane bitter honey and abba zabbas
snow caps is still relevant to this day
have you ever had a bit of honey i don't
think i don't know maybe you know maybe
it a hot it's a halloween candy
sting i don't get rid of mary jane i'm
not defending this disgusting i know
have you ever had a uh abba zaba
disgusting
they're old school candy they're only
one stars don't count but snow caps
you don't get married
to you i know i know i understand what
you're saying fortitude let me you
yes still being relevant but still being
sold often and still
there's a reason they're at the movie
theater there's a reason they're at the
movie theater
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm stepping on you
go ahead no it's okay no i'm sorry i'm
stuck
on you a lot too okay okay all right i
love you but listen
there's a reason at the movie theater
because the manager of every movie
theater or the amc chain president or
whatever said
we got to put something in here for
these 98 year olds that come to these
matinees
or we're going to look like age
discriminators put
something they know behind the counter
and somebody went
how about snow caps they're i don't know
i think you can get a year supply
for 12 no way dude old people have
popcorn let them have whatever they want
you you you can't don't give me that
argument i have never
seen you somebody order something no
that's like oh my god this lasted a
hundred years it must be [ __ ]
okay you get a 100 year old car 100 a
home
100 year old piece did you drive 100
year old car would you hop in 100 euro
car
take it over take it to the drive-in i'm
not sure if cars are 100 years old yet
yeah they are they came out like 112 or
whatever yeah okay
but would you drive a 100 year old car
would you wear a hundred-year-old pair
of pants
no you're like it smells like moth balls
this is experienced
in cars but what we're saying is if a
candy has stood the test of time it has
the title of longest candy in production
and it's three counterparts that were
relevant when it came out
are no longer really those are they're
still around sure but but
compare them to the the the the
relevance of the snow cap to this day
you got you know but people go i'm
telling you right now people go in there
and
some people are snow capped give me snow
cap will give me death
oh swear to god lying some people like
him i've literally really really really
like we don't have snow caps and then
they'll be like i don't want anything
i have no literally never anywhere in my
life seen somebody order snow caps ever
ever ever ever on top of it i've seen
people eat junior mints before they sell
caps which i think is insane
because i think that's like eating a box
of toothpaste i actually really like
junior mints i like them
in ration small rations and i think i
think that they don't get enough credit
neither does the peppermint patty
and recently i had a peppermint
chocolate and i was like oh my god dear
god i've been missing
peppermint in my chocolate don't you
know raisin heads by the way
i like a peppermint patty but the small
ones raisinettes
invented 1927 in my hometown baby
philadelphia i'll tell you what i'll go
on record right now i think raisin nets
is the shittiest candy out there
oh you're crazy one of the shittiest
candies out there you're crazy
so it is so weirdly sweet
it's bursting with raisins oh it's so
weird that this candy is sweet
i hate this sweet candy i mean the
reason
up against the pure sweetness of that
milk chocolate dude it is a beautiful
collision
in your mouth dude it's why cookies have
raisins and chocolate chips sometimes
it is everything that sweetness is
supposed to i don't want a box of them
okay and you have
balls on you telling me that snow caps
are for the old people
raisins are for the old people raisins
when the old people go to the movie
theater which by the way soon will be us
they want raisins uh-huh it's raisins
they want raisins in their candy to me
that's an old people candy and let me
tell you something
raisiness would be nothing if not for
movie theaters and if we have a problem
this year when movie theaters go the way
the dodo bird because
what are you getting there they're gonna
fall you think you're snow capper you
think your snow caps are gonna carry the
flag without movie theaters keeping them
out of any chocolate shop and
not one of the top sellers anywhere any
chocolate chip you wear
any chocolate shop has its own form of
raisinets of chocolate-covered raisins
right
with all the other chocolate covers it's
wonderful
any chocolatier you go to has non
perel's anyone
listen to me you tell listen i asked you
about snow caps
and that's off a shelf all the time you
do
i love raisinettes you do but that's not
what we're all
raising that's at the store yes you'll
buy raisin nets
seven eleven who did that i don't know
who did that
so i not only do i not know somebody
who's ever bought snow caps i've never
seen a human being eat snow caps in my
life [ __ ] i gotta
snow cats downstairs you would you would
you wanna go get
i'll put some cap in your mouth right
now no block a blocker i'll cap your ass
go get it go get it
yeah go get a snapchat that's what the
fans have been asking for go get your
precious snow
you're a step capped from prunes oh now
bring those snow caps back up
and if you have plain raisins bring
those up too
i'm excited so you're back we got a bag
of california golden raisins here now
i'm not sure what kind of raisins go
inside
uh uh raisonettes i'm assuming it's the
dark raisins
but because every raisin that is
polished
to resemble a beam of sunshine i
wouldn't be surprised if it is a golden
raisin inside
they look like shriveled roaches
raisins so we got trader joe's raisins
not
quite razor nets look at this beautiful
thing
tell them that that's not the real snow
cap either full
of chocolate and how they you know how
the thing comes down probably and goes
like that
and then it raises it up like a little
like a like it looks like a ufo
of dark belgian chocolate it's just
covered
with the with the uh with the white
candy on it i just
i it just this is i mean this is
unbelievable
for a good two three minutes hold on
it's trader joe's
it plays into it a little bit but
whatever
so we're not eating quite the candy of
either choice here i mean this is just a
larger version of the snow cap here we
go get it twisted as the kids ready
yeah well no they're using a different
chocolate i have no idea
but i'll taste it
be true you're treating yourself
that's exactly what i thought it was
gonna be tasty can put a goddamn
uh chocolate chip in your mouth that for
some reason
has crunchy eggs on top of it that's
what it tastes like so
good it is so good no
you guys wanted to hear us eat food i
told you for 25 episodes it's not a good
idea
now i listen to this you got a raisin
i don't know the acronym all right amsr
mri you chase it with a raisin it's
wonderful
no i'm sorry oh my god it's so good
even though you will generate even after
you're done you won't bite that in
spider-man chunks of chocolate this is
not
a raisin give me some raisins what do
you think i'm gonna go ahead they're
right there
wait don't you need to raise mix it with
the chocolate
actually it feels like i'm eating like a
shriveled piece of someone's skin
oh stop it it it feels like flesh
textured
it feels odd it's gotta mix it with the
chocolate because that's what we're
doing here
the interesting i'm gonna mix your your
raisin with my snow cap that's what i
just did and it made your snow cap a
thousand times better it didn't i know
what's gonna happen here i don't want
fruit like i don't want raisin juice in
my chocolate i didn't want a snow cap in
my mouth i did it because that's the
show
bite the chocolate
i mean it even sounds hardier as you
chew it sounds better
sounds better it's disgusting oh no it's
not it is yes no it's not i swear oh go
stick it up your ass
i didn't i didn't make a rash judgment i
waited the whole time i was
still around and i gave it a couple of
moments and it's just
raisin juice shooting all over my mouth
there is no juice shooting out of the
raisin cell
they're dry fruit they're juicy raisin
juice
no it's a dried grape
there's no juice shooting out of it oh
no what's in my mouth right now
raising me
[Music]
oh that sounds gross yeah i won't raise
the meat i thought all right movies
let's go to the polls i want to see what
some of the fans have to say raisins
raisinets are just chocolates too much
it doesn't go this is someone
someone's full let's see what the people
have to say it's too sugary and sweet
and and it tastes like a prune it's hard
all of a sudden someone's like here's
chocolate
chocolate covered fruit is such a huge
business and chocolate covered raisins
arguably lead that pack right next to
cherries
i i just think i just think that people
you're gonna like that
you're gonna either like that or you're
not gonna like it i don't know i think
you know what i think raisinets and snow
caps
are similar in that way now by the way i
think you're gonna get a lot of people
who say i love and hate both of them
let now here's the thing no no don't
scroll
wait wait wait pimp don't scroll away
because i want to read that first one
the uh uh
before we read any how do you think this
hold on wait wait don't read it yet
before we read anything
they do this how do you think this is
gonna go cause i think you're gonna get
the [ __ ] kicked out of you
i do feel like raisinets are straight-up
mouse turds
but i think we're gonna i think i'm
gonna win
i think i got the win here he is here's
what i think i think you have an
advantage because raisonette is a is a
more popular candy
that's what i think ultimately okay do i
think that people with
good palates feel like snow caps are
better than raisins yes they do
good i mean it's literally like saying
like do you like dark chocolate
it's literally like having a bag of
peanuts and being like this is candy and
it's like no
it's one thing in a bag
i don't know man my body doesn't feel
right when i'm chewing raisinets
my mouth my mouth wasn't my body doesn't
feel like when you're chilling
my mouth feel it feels weird it's like
what's going on here
i don't wanna i don't wanna almost
sounds like a like you need a more
sophisticated palate
as you just said all right uh it's razor
nets are just
i'm just reading can i give you let me
give you this maybe first couple of
scoops of raisin nuts
scoops first couple of shaking them out
of the boxes like you know
first couple of throws in the mouth like
okay i'm getting the burst of raisin and
chocolate it's a little sweet for my
taste it's a little gooey a little weird
but i get it maybe i get it i i
understand what you
kind of mean once you get halfway
through that box or toward the end of
that box
i am dry heaving on raisins it is
way too much raisin and chocolate for
consumption in one sitting
it's going to ruin all of all of
clifford maybe if you weren't
throwing them into your mouth by the
handful as you just described yourself
you're raising that one at a time yeah i
ate one at a time
no you don't yes i do no i feel like
this is the larry david moment
we were like yes i know and i buy a
decent sized box
and i i ended up having about 25 raising
that so i'm happy and that's the end of
it
there's no 25 raising that's in a box
yeah there is no there's not a raise
in the box a small box the small box a
package
yeah the small little box of raisins or
the little bag it's like 20
things yeah the box is a movie theater
size that's where you throw me off
you're saying box if we're talking to
the box of the movie theater by the way
half it's it's a badge it's just big on
the inside i know yeah so it's not 25
though i think it's more than that
but my point remains i truly with all my
heart of hearts i'm gonna look you in
your eyeballs with mine
and tell you that i do not believe that
you eat raisins one at a time
you don't need to believe it and i don't
need to prove it to you
i feel like you might
i want to read these comments raisinets
are just chocolate-covered [ __ ] turds
that i'd still choose over snow caps
whoa didn't see that coming snow caps
let's make chocolate chips annoying
raisin hats let's make raisins worse
of course that's when neither of us
agree with that one
you want to talk movie theater all right
skip it i'm not i can't i hate when
people do that
if candy looks like it can be used as a
movie prop
for tiny animal droppings i'm not eating
it i gotta vote snow caps for this one
i'll take disgust all right i'm not even
going to
okay uh yep should it wet
what are these just no caps of a 79 year
olds
that have a picture of nixon hanging
above us
in the garage oh man put that man on the
board for the win
or the woman i'm sorry samantha that
might be our winner
that's hilarious this is the first i had
to pick one it's snow caps overall
i feel like it's the more creative snack
than raisins covered in chocolate
who the [ __ ] thinks raisins are good
i'd rather eat dry wall before i eat
[ __ ] snow caps
it has the same texture less calories
and the shame of eating
will kill me just as quickly
if you actually want to enjoy the movie
snow caps if you're getting blown and
not
[Laughter]
that could be the winner too that's a
tough call
holy dude i should now that i'm reading
now that we're reading these
i'm not sure who's going to win i don't
know
uh if 20 20 presidential candidates were
candies this is what they would be
horrible choices these are the worst
choices
since keeping the kid or killing it oh
my god
jesus christ
raising that's a straight garbage snow
caps are for people who want to feel
poor
anything with raisins is not as good as
anything without
raisins that's for me then right yes
okay who who chooses snow caps i don't
like either but i would gladly eat a
raisin over what probably joe derosa is
forcing oh
you're wrong yeah you guys you make bold
claims and get it wrong
let me guess joe is going to confuse
prunes and raisins again
dog [ __ ] both are dog [ __ ] and one
literally looks like it
you've been doing great with the
matchups and this one is not the one
love you though
god
all right i think it's a two-way tie i
gotta
i i think we have our first ever two-way
win in the comments it's the
nixon pick and the getting blown during
the
those are both so funny man like i i got
it
right so samantha follow samantha
uh it's at samc
0 or sorry at s-a-m-c-0
r-s-e-l-l-o uh
she wins with her nixon comment and then
our second winner today
is where the hell do you go
there it is oh yeah there it is grand
master uh oh oreo
kush dragon wow
you can follow him at u n
t o t e n capital
s all right humble pie segment drum roll
this right now because
i truly do not know and and the votes
are
unless it's not refreshed we're closing
in on
all right 8 000 votes is that low
i should i spelled snow caps wrong i'm
never gonna get over it
is that low 8 000 uh it's like
it's a little low it's a little bit but
but we haven't been going as long
by the way there were people saying are
these just east coast stacks i guess
they don't have
razor nets i think snow capped is the
one that people don't know what they are
shh that's where i might lose that's
where i might lose they probably know
what a non perella is
but they don't understand that it's look
some people are saying out of hatred or
raised nets they're just going to vote
for snow caps
you know i don't know what you're doing
arguing for a reason
please that's not what i associate the
movie theater with joe
it's not even terminated too hope i can
handle it's not about what
you associate it with it's about what i
associate it with do you understand
do you understand you associate so stay
in your lane
chances are a lot chances are a lot of
the movies you've seen you've been
chewing on raisins
yeah no no no chances are i was having
twizzlers and a cherry coke but that
wasn't the match-up today
the mat my other go-to was raisonettes
and yours is
snow caps you lunatic i it's crazy i
didn't even know they saw them at the
movies until you brought this up yes she
did
all right you're lying a lot today
you're lying a lot today i'm not lying i
just wear it
i swear to god listen to me when you're
at the movies
please listen to me when you're at the
movies especially in new york
i want you all to feverishly look around
for joe derose i want you to spot him
and i want you to tape him eating
his raisinets more than one at a time
don't ever let him live that down
there's no way he puts his meaty paws
into that little box opening and pulls
out a singular razor net
and then chews on one raisin and does
that through the entire box right that's
a lot of we all know it's a lie all
right and if you're at the movies
and you want snow caps go ahead and get
some snow caps i apologize in advance
you're gonna have to wrestle them
out or a 97 year old flappers crippled
hands
all right go ahead yes
no yes oh
give me a break yes i thought i was
losing
give me a break oh baby
[Applause]
yeah oh shoot
15 points right there babe decent win
not even too close 55 45 is close this
is
fairly decent oh i thought i was gonna
lose
i thought i was gonna lose that though
raisins were way more popular
oh this is such a sweet sweet win for me
no pun intended a sweet sweet almost a
two sweet win
almost like a razor net this is a razor
net win for me
57.1 snow caps
to 42.9 percent raisinets it's about 8
200 votes so far
and that's pretty decisive i am so happy
right now because i really
thought that i was taking an l here and
my snow cap people i told you they're
out there i told you there's snow cap
rider dies out there
and they happen to be on the net today
and they cast they made their voices
heard today
okay the snow cat baby i even spelled it
wrong that might even be
confusion that might lend to another
couple percentage points i continue to
lose faith in this country
just end it end it end it
all right check out the no brush network
share the show
rate the show tell a friend about the
show uh
taste buds on youtube the original taste
buds the only taste buds yes
um and uh check out savolicanocomedy.com
for all
uh dates and joe jonah's a comedy duck
yeah go ahead say the line i still love
you love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste bud
oh one thing we want to mention to you
guys we now have eclipse page
which is basically a highlight reel of
all the fun little moments from all the
episodes that
uh we disseminate and we hope that you
share so if you like our show please
check out the
taste buds clips page and then tweet
about it
share your funniest bits and help us
grow the show